beyond glasgow beyond the ambition the
forests of great abaco have gone
the storm was two years ago and yet for
mile after mile it still looks like this
a wasteland
and the communities around have hardly
rebuilt and do you remember
the storm very well yes sir it was very
bad it's something i never want to
experience again
zander gardner is just 18 showing us
around an island that puts the cop
conference and his future in context
this right here this is this was
actually a school the money to rebuild
from the bahamas most powerful storm on
record never
came it's a long journey but
we'll make it
marsh harbour feels forgotten frozen in
that moment two years ago
beyond the sound of a slow rebuild
everyone here wonders what the future
holds
in glasgow the jargon is loss and damage
and adaptation finance a push by island
nations like this to demand the big
polluting countries pay for the
consequences here and the text agreed on
is they say disappointing mechanisms but
no commitments and it's not just the
destruction but the displacement
so your mom lives down here
okay
maybe we can go and meet her these pods
are temporary homes for all those who've
lost theirs
what about you know the next storm
because that must be such a worry that
another one will come
i know i'm gonna be here
i had to go
go somewhere else
where the weather's better
where the weather is better
what's clear is that today's internally
displaced at tomorrow's refugees they
become another nation's burden
how long have you been here
a few pods down 21 year old dominique
invites us into her temporary home
wow look at this crab it's lunchtime and
mom gardenia is cooking any little rain
or thunderstorms
you can see like they're a little scared
and they go back to thinking about it so
just trying to get back in some housing
that's gonna i wanna say hopefully
protect us if another hurricane was to
pass here again chatting to dominique
it's clear that she's no time to think
about the climate science or the
culprits because she is living it right
now for her what matters is her family's
survival and existence and that's sad to
say but that's the honest truth
but now that we're talking about that
and how you're telling me about the
conference trust me i'm definitely gonna
look that up
the weather changes fast here it's
hurricane season and they're holding
their breath up the coast is the fishing
community of cooper's town
a break in the rain is a chance for a
chat with local firefighter kirk murray
a man clearly scarred by what he
experienced two years ago but not
defeated you know we if we give up now
all hope is lost if we come together as
a country a neighboring country we could
all do this together so it's a fight
together because we're we're jessica if
they cough we catch the cold so if we do
this together we ain't nothing could
stop us you know the really alarming
thing is that whatever the deal in
glasgow whether or not countries stick
to their pledges here it is probably
already too late even the most modest
temperature rise predictions would see
sea level rises of up to a meter and
that would put this entire island
community underwater
they are images not of the power of
nature but the consequence of our impact
on it an inability to protect against it
here they are beyond the pledges the
promises the compromises in glasgow